ميدانيا ايضا في مقاطعه خاركيز قالت هيئه
الاركان الاوكرانيه ان القوات الروسيه
تستهدفت مدنا وبلدات في محور كوبيانسك ما
اسفر عن اصابات
وانذلاعي حرائق
جنبا في خرسون قالت الاداره العسكريه
الاوكرانيه ان قصف روسيا خلف قتلى واصابات
قبل دقائق من دخول الهدنه التي اعلنتها
روسيا حيزه ذكر الجيش الاوكراني وان
القوات الروسيه قصفت مركزا للاطفاء ومنزلا
مجاوره
الينا من موسكو مراسلنا امين درغامي ومن
كيف مراسلنا تامر الصمادي اهلا بكما وابدا
معك امين بعد اعلان القوات الموليه لروسيا
في دونيتك قصف الجيش الاوكراني لهذه
المقاطعه لثلاث مرات ما مصير هذه الهدنه
التي اعلنها بوتين الان
[تصفيق]
وربما
طويلا او حتى على الاقل
نهايتها عند الساعه 12:00 من منتصف يوم غد
وزاره الدفاع قبل قليل اعلنت على انها ردت
على مواقع اطلاق تابعه للجيش الاوكراني في
كل من مقاطعات لوغانس وخار كيف ودونيس بعد
ان تعرضت مواقعها لقصف من تلك المناطق
وقال بانها قمعت مصادر النيران الاوكرانيه
وفي بيانها طبعا اليوميه الوزاره هكدت على
ان اجانب الروسي همم التزم منذ دخول هذه
الهدنه حيز التنفيذ عند منتصف اليوم
بتوقيت موسكو لكن الجيش الاوكراني وصل قصف
تجمعات السكانيه وايضا مواقع
الروسي قبل ذلك طبعا سلطات دونيات سواء
مركز الدفاع المشترك في المدينه او عمده
مدينه دمياط كالمولي لروسيا اكدوا على ان
القصف لم يتوقف سواء قبل دخول هذه الهدنه
او خلال الساعات التي دخول الهدنه احياء
عده في مدينه دمياط بحسب السلطات هناك
تعرضت للقذف
المدعي وهي احياء كيف سكي وبيتروسكي وايضا
كلينيس في كل تلك الحياه تعرضت همم
انطلاقا من هذا اذا اضفنا له طبعا تصريحات
همم دينيس بوشينل رئيس
الموالي لروسيا الذي قال بان هذه الهدنه
لا تعني اعطاء فرصه لاجانب الاوكراني من
اجل تحسين وضعه على اجابه او اعاده همم
الدفع او الدفع تعزيزات جديده همم طبعا كل
هذا يمكن او يتقاطع على على الاقل مع
تصريحاتها او المعلومات القادمه من محور
ضخم والتاليوم وساري اعلام روسيه تتحدث عن
تقدم تحرزه القوات الروسيه في محور بصمه
المشكله اساسا من قوات فاجنر وحديث عن
اختراق دفاعات الجيش الاوكراني في مدينه
سوليدار وانسحاب القوات الاوكرانيه باتجاه
الشمال والغرب